we've got mama june road to
redemption this new chapter of your life
is about to be released out into the
world for everybody to watch and be a
part of
how are you feeling i'm feeling really
good because
last season we ended and i shared my
road
to addiction i showed everything last
season so this season will
you know you better get your kleenexes
ready better get your laughs on
because it's going to be another
emotional season it's about you know
me and gino now as of the 27th of this
month
we'll be 14 months clean off of cocaine
and been that way
no no relapses so if it makes one person
wake up and realize that you know
addiction
their addiction is really going to kill
them one day then i've done
me sharing my life with the world well i
want to say
formally congratulations achieving your
sobriety
and maintaining it and those milestones
it's so important and
it's really wonderful to hear um i'm
curious as the episodes
start airing what is it like for you to
have to relive a lot of these moments
the good
and the bad you know that's a crazy
question and this sounds
this may be bad on my part to say this
but like last season no i didn't watch
much of it i didn't want to see that
craziness because in our addiction
we was helping people that had
addictions get clean
which is crazy right um this season
um i'm going to be live tweeting going
back to live streaming that i've done
for many many years
what are you most excited for fans to
see and and what are you most
dreading having to relive um
you know having to go back and talk
about that lifestyle that we had
i don't ever want to go back to that
lifestyle i wake up every morning and
tell myself
i'm going to stay clean these next 24
hours and that's my
saying every day me and gina both have
been fortunate enough not to have a slip
up but a lot of people have relapsed
during this tobit virus
so addiction is real this covet virus is
real and so you're gonna see all that
you know filming during covet virus us
spotting
our our court case still that the drug
charges in alabama
what i'm going through through that and
rebuilding my life
my brand um trying to raise back up to
the top
production kind of holds me accountable
too you know i have to take weekly drug
testing
does that mean that if you fail a drug
test the show is
yes if you don't go take a drug test one
week or you
me or gina fell then i can't i can't be
in the show
i want to get into some of the things
that we're going to see this season
um of course you mentioned your your
health your sobriety
what exactly does sobriety mean to you
and and how are you maintaining it
um like i said the 27th of march
we will be we will be 14 months clean a
lot of naysayers as i like to say those
closet
fans haters um you know
p off you know what i mean i go to all
these different rehabs
and speak and give back from my gift
that honestly is what keeps me
clean what keeps me sober because those
people that are
fighting that fight that i know i fought
through it gives me
so much more gratitude more gratitude
than you will ever imagine
and gives me they give so much more back
to me than i can ever give to them if
that makes sense
okay so no drugs and no alcohol no
no hell no okay and and do you see this
as a lifelong commitment
yes i mean if you get recovery and
you're in recovery i
i've got a very addictive personality so
you know what my addiction is right now
my addiction is um
getting my brand back getting you know
working on the relationships with the
kids
and also working in a rehab because now
i'm a year clean i can work in a rehab
what does uh a sober night with
gino and and june look like how what
kind of an impact has that had on your
relationship
we sit at home we watch a lot of tv um
and we don't go out um it's either
cooking a meal
and watching what favorite shows that
night
and you know talking about what we need
to do
to work on our relationships with all of
our kids a big focus this season
seems to be the emotional aspect
of your relationship with your daughters
and
your relationship with gino seems to be
a huge
obstacle between you we all hated geno
because mama picked him and drugs over
us
how do you feel when you watch your
daughters talking about that how do you
feel when you watch them
i mean as a mom you know it's hard you
know they say like in the 12-step
program you know try to make an amend
recovery just like addiction came number
one and it sounds selfish as a mom
but recovery is even more selfish and i
have to
i have to be good for me to be good for
somebody else
my recovery is important to me just like
gino's recovery is important to him but
i don't stay with you because we're in
recovery
gina's recovery is his recovery and my
recovery is my recovery
do you think there's a a world that can
exist
where your daughters find forgiveness
in geno in order to make amends with you
i definitely think there will be um i
said it's just a work in progress
um i think it will because me and the
girls have always been close
yeah and i think a lot of fans and a lot
of people period think that he had the
influence of drugs but the reality is it
is i was the one with all the drug
dealers i was the one that was hooking
him up with the dope
um so you know it's just like i said
it's uh the best way to describe it to
somebody
it's a work in progress how is your
relationship with gino today
um it's very good um we've been together
for five years and we've been through
some
um whether it be recovery you know other
things
um and it is really good um
you know we both are still fighting our
case in alabama that we got
for drug charges a couple years ago he
said this is kind of like a dark little
cloud over my head
and over gino's head that we are still
fighting today two years
over two years later is there still fear
about
what could happen yeah yeah
i mean we don't know the unknown is what
i don't like
i want to be able to go into the d.a and
say hey i'm doing good i'm passing these
drug tests i've completed rehab
do i think that i should just get a slap
on the wrist like a lot of celebrities
do
no because i i did do something wrong um
and i have to face my consequences just
like you know the best hope
would be like like me to hopefully do
the first offenders
um and we both get probation but that's
not a
that's not a guarantee you know um we're
both facing to
a felony charge of peace and a
misdemeanor charge well i have got you
in my my deepest thoughts and prayers
and i'm keeping my fingers crossed i
love the good work that you're doing
with taking your sobriety and this
pandemic
seriously um in regards to your
relationship with gino you mentioned
you've been
together for five years at this point
how serious are things do you guys have
conversations about maybe taking the
next step
i mean he was with somebody for 26 years
married for 21
and he's only been married one time i've
never been married um
and i'm something um one day
maybe who knows i mean the situation
works the way it's working now
and you know i'm only his second serious
relationship his whole entire life
so you know it's just kind of you know
day by day you know we're
we're riding the ride let's put it that
way your girls seem
to really take issue with gina we can't
just forgive and forget overnight you
have let a man come between your kids
she's got to prove to us that she's all
better if it came down to
you gotta pick us or you gotta pick him
what do you say to that
i mean that's a no-brainer i mean you
always pick your kids
men come and go kids and kids kids in
some family always stay
the opening of your of your season
premiere absolutely killed me when you
called
us an ice cream sundae a smoothie that's
something that i'm going to now start
doing
as it is look i am looking hot in my my
little uh
sports bra and look that is a smoothie
because look i put milk in it
and you gotta put milk in this i use
almond milk come on now
you know and you said something like
sprinkles are protein so you really
you've got all the ingredients there um
i'm curious
how are you feeling how is your health
today
um i mean i'm honestly like i put on
about 70 pounds of covered weight
i'll get it off um it's gonna take some
time i mean
um i'm i prefer to be healthy and happy
and clean and doing what i'm doing and
be fat when when do you
personally feel your best um
personally i feel my best like now i
feel like when i did my reveal
first season i was way too skinny and i
think
that now at 2 50 um i was like 185 when
i went to rehab when i'm at 250 right
now
i'm just kind of happy i feel kind of
comfortable where i'm at right now
[Music]
you